given this polynomial again the gray 3
factorize it if it has a double version
okay sir what are you doing this thing I
want to think to what we know about the
multiple series right I have a root of
multiplicity 2 that means the derivative
is going to have a root of multiplicity
1 at the same place whatever it whatever
that happens to be whatever wherever
that double reed is okay now just before
we actually launch into the calculus can
you see why this ends up being so useful
in this particular question right
what makes this cubing awful to deal
with it is that guy right like what's
what's out of the way of factorizing and
cubing
well much it not just long division you
can find the first factor originally
right so you can plug the numbers into
that and it's just like I know it's
gonna be something terrible okay I have
some reasonable gifts to this thinking
back to why I know this is um this is
morning right so I am expecting
something of this form
right but not knowing whether it has a
young not knowing much about alpha and
beta and gamma like none of them in
complex all that kind of thing right
you're never going to guess a complex
rate so you want you just kind of put me
in frame now just as a bit of tip see
how this here right trigger point five
clearly can only be a profit of alpha
beta and gamma
do you see that like it has to come out
of all the codes of theft so I am
guessing out of alpha beta and gamma
what it is probably five it's just a
reasonable guess because that's that's
an I can't see any other obvious factors
we'll find out more about this well if
there it's a cubic so it has to have at
least one real root right so hopefully I
should find that one if I'm long
correct they know divide but all of that
is still bit move it as well we know
more about this so we don't need to go
to those lengths hey let's go to
calculus now I can say P - right and you
can see I can take out my factor of
three and this ends up being quite
simple to factorize when I perfected
yeah like I said pay - right you can see
it's for two routes that corresponds to
being cubic that corresponds to the
magnet it's all true stationary points
and that's not surprising but since it
has a double group I know that one of
these stationary points must be one of
the zeros of a polynomial does that make
sense so one of these write x equals
negative 7 or x equals 1 must be a root
ball not just p - but the original
function so therefore I can include it
test this out now I'm going to look at
this and make an educated guess and I'm
not even gonna bother putting in one
like a single field what's the point
you're never going to get there okay but
to make sure that I'm not confusing
myself I am going to evaluate payoff
negative jq7
just to make sure I'm not losing myself
okay this is going to be minus 343 plus
9 lots of 49 minus 21 lots of negative
seven minus two five okay and you can go
ahead you can evaluate that pretty sure
we're gonna get two
yep good so therefore what have I
established I've started ok I know where
the stationary points will be now I know
that this stationary point is one of the
routes okay
so therefore what can i what can I say
about paybacks if I know
I found the double root so what does
that tell me about the factorization
very minute so so the factor is a at or
X minus alpha which is plus seven so
that's X plus seven it because it's
twice and then I'm going to have some
lot of being hanging off on the end of
equality no next one
at this point you can do the math but we
said before you can just evaluate P law
okay so evaluating at x equals zero on
the left hand side by definition zero
zero zero negative turn to 45 what's
that going to be able to
this is 49 very clean and this is
negative beta so it looks to me like
they give like maybe yeah yeah so I'm
gonna get a bigger five yeah so
therefore now I've actually completed
since I've got British that means I'm
unaffected so I can say therefore P of X
is already got had base before and now I
have these boy that was a lot better
than trying nine or ten instances of the
factor theorem right over my head now
like I said if if we didn't know it said
we forgot this okay
I actually mentioned we anticipated
before that five was likely to be one of
them and in fact just as a sneaky sort
of option you can't always rely on this
because of possibility being commented
but they can't decide to 45 and if you
just like to freak like me Cap'n and
then you press the factorized button
it's going to hate you the prime
factorization and you have some very
good guesses where is four so yeah where
is this mythical button well I don't
blame me because my calculator didn't
have this when I was going to now see on
mine that I have right now it's just
above the degrees minutes seconds button
so you guys factorize it hands to you
the factorization yeah
yeah that's this is very true so we're
lucky in that this particular number
happens to be like the factors that we
wanted they're all prime do you notice
that that's kind of what makes it easy
but as its pointed out well let's let's
do like four times six times day if you
say if you've got like 192 here right
you say 192 and your shift factorize
you've got 2 to the 6 times 3 which is
many combinations of different numbers
you may have to try so you want to come
back to this